okay before we go to break I do want to
squeeze in just one other one of these
stories
um it really appears as though being a
right-wing radio host and or a
right-wing Pastor can be very very
dangerous Bob enyart
conservative fire brand and Pastor big
anti-vaxx dies of covet 19.
The Denver Post is reporting that the
pastor of the Denver Bible Church and
indelible talk show host has died from
covet Bob enyart was one of the smartest
and without question why is this person
I've known Said Fred Williams his
co-host on the real science radio show
real science can you imagine enyart and
his wife refused to get the vaccine due
to abortion concerns
in October enyart successfully sued the
state over Mass mandates and capacity
limits in churches of rare legal Victory
against public health mandates
instituted during the pandemic
um you might be saying abortion what
what are you what are you talking about
I checked out the uh website
and they have a section coveted vaccines
where they say this is from last month
guys guys dead now Bob and Cheryl have
sworn off taking the Pfizer moderna and
Johnson vaccines because as those firms
admit they tested the three products on
the cells of aborted babies there are
however vaccines being developed morally
though none are scheduled to be
available until the end of this year our
friends over at cogforlife.org lists
these coming ethical vaccines Merc
sanofi and from novavax
the Charlotte Lozier Institute reports
innovo and bioen Tech are also producing
vaccines developed without fetal tissue
so while it is not inherently sinful to
take an immorally developed vaccine
we urge everyone to boycott Pfizer
moderna and Johnson to further increase
social tension wow and put pressure on
the child Killers remember many
institutions and celebrities who have
been pro-choice all along are now
calling to legalize infanticide which
they call after birth abortion so
there's no bottom to their Abyss sanofi
Pasteur has discontinued using fetal
tissue for the polio vaccine well so
maybe soon they'll allow people to get
the polio vaccine at this church these
people are causing death
he died he died now another one of these
guys who died but they are also causing
death elsewhere by convincing people of
this stuff so another anti-vaxx radio
host who is also a pastor
just last week saying no Pfizer no
moderna no no Johnson as they call it
um he has now died
uh
what can you say what can you say we'll
have more on that on our Instagram at
davidpackman show